hundreds of people made their own
statement against racism at a vigil last
night in Shaw's Ville it followed an
early memorial service for Heather hire
who was killed in Saturday's violence
David big no is in Shaw's Ville David
good morning Charlie good morning we're
on the Downtown Mall here in
Charlottesville again at the message
wall and look what we found
a beautiful memorial in honor of Heather
hire who's a household name this morning
because of what happened to her last
night on the campus of the University of
Virginia there was a vigil a memorial we
didn't know what was gonna happen or how
many people were going to show up so we
went and look at what we found this is
what happens when peaceful people unite
this is a turning point this is this is
a better place to be many in the crowd
wore purple in honor of Heather hire
whose memorial service was held earlier
Wednesday I'd rather have my child but
by golly if I gotta give her up we're
gonna make it count Heather's mother
Susan bro challenged mourners to stand
up and make a difference
much like her daughter she was a firm
believer in whatever she believed and
let's do that the 32 year old died
Saturday when a white supremacist
allegedly used his vehicle to attack
peaceful marchers they tried to kill my
child to shut her up well guess what you
just magnified her Heather's father Marc
broke down repeatedly she wanted
equality and in this issue of the day of
her passing she wanted to put down hey
we lost Alfred Wilson was hires boss he
says she once broke up with a boyfriend
who didn't like the fact that she worked
for a black man okay you've been seeing
these guys for like two years she said I
don't know
was more important everybody's cheap
treated equal Heather hire had a
statement it was her favorite if you're
not angry you're not paying attention
Nora President Trump tweeted about
Heather saying she was a truly special
young woman David thank you her parents
gave amazing eulogies there thank you